العمود الفقري للجيش الامريكي يصل
اوكرانيا الولايات المتحده تنشئ مصنعا
دفاعيا كبيرا في كييف روسيا تنزل بوحوش
جديده الى المحيطات بينما ترد المانيا
بامداد الاوكران بعشرات الزوارق الحربيه
وقرده غربيه اقصد وفضيحه غربيه في الاسلحه
المقدمه لاوكرانيا وموسكو توجه صواريخها
ومسيراتها الى اوديسا في هجوم واسع الجيش
الاوكراني يعلن عن صيد روسي ثمين ورد
الروس لا يتاخر رئيس المحكمه الدوليه
يتورط بدخول قائمه بوتين السوداء السعوديه
تعلن عن مشروع نووي وفرنسا ترفع رايتها
البيضاء في النيجر
اختناق الح الغربيه
الصنبور الغربي يشتد تاره وينقطع تاره
اخرى عن اوكرانيا ولا شيء اصبحك السابق
وبعد مطالبات اوكرانيه عده ووعود امريكيه
فهي دبابات التي تعتبر من الجيل الثالث من
الدبابات القتاليه الامريكيه والعمود
الفقري للجيش الامريكي تصل اوكرانيا وفقا
لما اكده الرئيس الاوكراني
جاء مباشره بعد تاكيد مسؤولين امريكيين في
وقت سابق ان المزيد من هذه الدبابات سيصل
الى اوكرانيا في الاشهر المقبله وكانت
اداره بايدن اواخر العام الماضي قد تعهدت
بارسال 31 دبابه من نوع ابرامز وها هو
المصدر يتحدث الحنفيه الامريكيه مفتوحه
على اخرها في الوقت الحالي كما يقول
المصريون حيث اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني
موافقه الولايات المتحده على انتاج اسلحه
مشتركه مع قائلا ان المشروع سيشمل تصميم
انظمه الدفاع الجوي ايضا وهنا لابد من
المصدر اعل
ن الرئيس على انتاج اسلحه مشتركه مع بلاده
لكن الحنفيه الامريكيه يبدو انها لا تتسع
للصواريخ بعيده المدى والطائرات الحربيه
هنا المرجان المتقاعد في سلاح الجو
البريطاني يصرح بان صواريخ التخنز التي
تدرس الولايات المتحده احتمال توريدها
لاوكرانيا قد تظهر في سوق السوداء مضيفا
لقناه سكاي نيوز كل مره عندما يتم تسليم
الاسلحه لاوكرانيا يوجد هناك احتمال ان
يظهر جزء منها في السوق السوداء برايكم هل
السوق السوداء الاوكرانيه هي حقا ما يمنع
وصول تلك الاسلحه ام ان هناك اسباب اخرى
لكن مهلا مهلا هنا مجله يزبك الامريكيه
تكشف ان معظم الدبابات التي تم ارسالها
الى اوكرانيا كانت معيوبه وتعاني من
مشكلات تقنيه وميكانيكيه وقر وزير الدفاع
الدنماركي بوجود عيوب في الدبابات حيث
كانت
الالمانيه الشهيره المحللون بدورهم يرجعون
هذه العيوب الى رغبه اوكرانيا في الحصول
على اسلحه باسرع وقت ممكن ما دفع حلفائها
الى ارسال قطع من المخزونات الفائضه لديهم
وكانهم ينسبون السبب الى التسرع وكما يقول
المثل في العجل الندامه وعلى ذكر الالمان
والدعم للالماني اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الالماني هذا الاسبوع عن حزمه جديده من
المساعدات العسكريه بقيمه 40 مئه مليون
يورو قيمه تخطط برلين لتوريد 50 زورقا
مسيرا الى اوكرانيا على الجانب الروسي
تمضي الامور وفقا ما يخطط لها قاده بوتين
وها هو مصنع امور الروسي يعلن انه سينزل
الى المياه قريبا سفينتين جديدتين طورهما
لصالح سلاح البحريه في الجيش وهما سفينه
تارجي
مع تبقي سفينتين صاروخيتين اخريين كما قال
بيان لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه والذي اشر الى
ان الوزاره وقعت مع مصنع امور لبناء سفن
حربيه في الميدان اشتغلت معارك الصواريخ
والمسيرات لتعلن الدفاع الروسي عن اسقاط
ثمن طائرات بدون طيار اوكراني فوق البحر
الاسود وشبه جزيره القرم ومقاطعتي
220 طائره مسيره 11 صاروخا اطلقت روسيا
وقالت مصادر محليه ان مخازن الحبوب في
ميناء اوديسا تعرضت لاضرار جسيمه جراء هذا
الهجوم ليعلن الجيش الاوكراني عن صيد
عسكري اقتنصته قواته وذلك باعلانك مقتل
قائد اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي الادمر
الفيكتور سوكلوف هي هجمات نفدت قوته في
قبل ايام واشار الجيش الاوكراني الى ان
الهجوم على مقر البحريه الروسيه في ادى
الى مقتل 34 ضابطا روسيا بحسب وكاله
راوترز بانتظار الرد الروسي لياتي الرد
الروسي على الفور حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسي ان قواتها شن الضربات الليليه قويه
ومكثفه على نقاط انتشار الاجانب وما
وصفتها بمراكز تدريب المخربين الاوكران
وحسب بيانات الوزاره الروسيه فقد تكبد
الجيش الاوكراني خسائر بشريه بنحو 840
جنديا خلال 24 ساعه اليكم الخبر كما هو في
المصدر فيما قال رئيس حركه نحن مع روسيا
فلاديميرغوف ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه
حررت قريه اوريخوفو شمال غربي مدينه بخمس
بعيدا عن معارك البارود وضعت ازاره
الداخليه الروسيه رئيس المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه
على قائمه المطلوبين
قد اصدر مذكره توقيف بحق الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في مارس الماضي الى الامم
المتحده وفي كلمته بالجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده لعرائس كولومبيا جوستافو الغرب
لحمايه فلسطين من الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
مثل ما يحمون اوكرانيا وانتقد بتروس
ديواجيتا معايير الغرب في الازمتين
الفلسطينيه والاوكرانيه داعيا الى عقد
مؤتمرين للسلام لانهاء الحربين فهل تصل
الرساله الكولومبيه للعربيه لننتقل الى
اذربيجان حيث اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها لحفظ سلامتك استلمت حتى الان 120
الف قطعه من الاسلحه الخفيفه والمضاده
للدبابات فضلا عن انظمه دفاع جوي ومئه
[موسيقى]
الاحداث والتطورات
في السعوديه اعلن وزير الطاقه السعوديه
عبد العزيز بن سلمان ان الرياضه تعتزم
بناء اول محطه للطاقه النوويه للانسان في
التنميه الوطنيه وانها تؤكد حقها في
الاستفاده من التقنيات النوويه السلميه
وجدد وزير الطاقه دعم السعوديه للوكاله
الدوليه من اجل تسخير التقنيه النوويه
لخدمه البشريه بينما اكد رئيس المعارضه
الاسرائيليه يا ايرلابيد انه يؤيد اتفاق
التطبيع مع السعوديه معلنا معارضته السماح
للمملكه بتخصيب اليورانيوم على اراضيها
لانه يشكل خطرا على امن اسرائيل الى
النيجر بعد شهرين من التهديد والوعيد بين
فرنسا والنيجر اعلن الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ان السفير الفرنسيه في النيجر
سيعود قريبا الى باريس وان القوات
الفرنسيه ستغادر هذا البلد بحلول نهايه
العام ليعلن المجلس العسكري في النيجر عن
ترحيبه بهذا الاعلان الفرنسي معتبرا ذلك
لحظه تاريخيه وخطوه جديده باتجاه السياده